Wolfgang I just saw Avengers infinity
war for the hundred something time now
and it's just as good this time as when
I saw it the first time and of course
after I see the movie I come home and I
go and look up different things that
I've noticed cuz each time you tend to
notice something a little bit different
that you didn't catch in the first time
and today I noticed some news that was
given to us by the Russo brothers
themselves about Avengers infinity war
and Avengers 4 there will be some
spoilers for those of you who haven't
seen Avengers infinity war yet but they
won't be till later on in the video so
stick around until I give you that
spoiler alert but off with some news
about Avengers 4 trailer but before we
do be sure to subscribe to my channel to
enter our giveaway for a speaker system
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel subscribe to the stupendous
waves channel leave a like and drop a
comment below with your favorite
superhero in a recent interview the
Russo brothers were asked when we might
see our first clip of Avengers 4 which
we got the sad response no idea turns
out they haven't cut any of the film
together yet in fact they haven't even
finished filming all of the scenes I
want to say that when they do start to
edit it they'll eventually find the film
and that's when they'll start to make
the trailer for it
unfortunately they said that they're not
going to get around to the editing into
the next two or three months so don't
expect a trailer anytime soon in fact
we'll probably see it at the end of the
year you who haven't seen infinity war
yet I'm sorry but here's your spoiler
alert from here on out we're going to be
talking about some events that happen in
infinity war Larusso was recently on a
podcast where he offered an explanation
of why the Hulk really didn't show up
Joe stated that he thinks many people
have interpreted it as the Hulk is
scared and he doesn't see that as the
case because he's had his butt kicked
before but he always loves a good fight
dead he thinks it's a reflective of the
journey from Ragnarok is that these two
characters are constantly in conflict
with each other over control and he
thinks that if the Hulk or to say why
it'd be that banner only wants Hulk for
fighting I think that he's had enough of
saving banners but so whether it's
because the Hulk is afraid of Thanos or
he's just tired of saving banners but it
looks like we'll see the Hulk in
Avengers 4 it's but not least a news the
Reese or other sort of
confirmed that the deaths and infinity
war will be reversed in a recent Q&A
they were asked how they made character
deaths impactful even when we know that
a character has a sequel such as Spider
Man or the guardians of the galaxy or we
almost certainly know that they have a
sequel such as Black Panther and Doctor
Strange answered instead of being vague
about it or stepping around the question
or simply saying that the character's
death were final they went on to say
that they made the deaths impactful
because of the emotional connection that
the audience shares with the characters
they're going to say that it is their
jobs as story tellers to tell the best
story that they can and make our
experience filled with as many emotions
as possible when we watch the film so
this in a way does in fact tell us that
the deaths will be reversed some way or
another whether that's the Avengers
getting the Infinity Gauntlet somehow or
using stark technology and Pym
technology to go back in the past it is
interesting to note that they did say at
the end of the interview they keep
trying to have game changers at the end
of each film but they are slowly moving
towards deconstruction so to me it seems
like they will in fact bring characters
back in and vengers for but they will
also be killing off some characters for
good in Avengers 4 so that's it for the
news update in this video concerning
Avengers 4 and Avengers and infinity war
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below and let me know if you
have any theories of your own if you
liked the video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to my channel to
join the wolf gang thank you so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]